ça fait maintenant cinq ans tant que les
snowbirds marque l'imaginaire des
canadiens c'est le cas de maryse
carmichael qui a appris à piloter un
avion à 16 ans lorsqu'elle était dans
les cadets de l'air intérieur s'est
finalement concrétisé en 2001 elle est
devenue la première femme pilote des
snowbirds
elle marquera l'histoire du célèbre
escadron une deuxième fois en 2010 en
étant promu au poste de commandant tu
véritable pionnière maryse carmichael et
fier d'avoir été un modèle pour d'autres
femmes dans un milieu majoritairement
masculin je dois dire que j'ai eu la
chance de voir le fruit de ce que j'ai
fait en 2001 2002 il ya une petite fille
de québec qui avait 16 tu m'as vu voler
et qui est elle a décidé qu'elle voulait
faire partie composées maintenant s'il a
un demi kilomètre de chez moi c'est une
bonne amie elle a fait partie des
nombreuses aussi alors le lien est très
étroit les acrobaties des snowbirds ont
épaté jean françois dupont dès son
enfance et aujourd'hui il est le chef de
cette équipe d'élite les rangs des
pilotes de son bel même le pouvoir des
membres de l'escadron
une certaine passion avec le sombre
depuis la toute jeune trop jeune temps
que moi j'allais quand j'étais jeune
mais les snowbirds ne sont pas à l'abri
des tragédies il y a deux mois le 17 mai
dernier
la capitaine jennifer kessy âgé de 35
ans est morte lorsque son avion s'est
écrasé à kamloops en colombie
britannique
les snowbirds participait alors à une
tournée pour remonter le moral des
canadiens en pleine pandémie
persévérance c'est pas vraiment le mot
qui décrit les gens avec qui je
travaille c'est que ça fait partie de
mon quotidien carton joint les forces
canadiennes il rien qui va marcher comme
prévu les tragédies impliquant les
snowbirds résonne particulièrement fort
à moose jaw en saskatchewan
la ville qui accueille cet escadron et
les snowboards sont actuellement cloués
au sol le temps d'une enquête entourant
la tragédie de kamloops
les festivités du 50ème anniversaire
sont reportés à l'an prochain en raison
de la pandémie
mais après 50 ans d'histoire les
snowbirds promettent un retour en force
dans le ciel du canada ici et me lemieux
radio canada
regina